we will turn now to the radical extreme
socialist democratic party tonight we
the American people
you should be alarmed just 24 hours ago
all the Democrats running for the
highest office in the land basically
pushed a Venezuela style socialism as
the solution to all of America's
problems by the way they didn't talk
once about the American economy and the
revival under Donald Trump shocking not
even a single question from their
friends and the media mob they called
for a hostile government takeover of the
entire private health care industry with
proposals to kick all Americans off
their private health care plans not an
option
they called for a hostile government
takeover of the private energy sector
putting all oil and gas companies out of
business hate to tell you that's the
lifeblood of our economy and boy what a
setback that would be now that we are
for the first time in 75 years energy
independent on a Trump they called for
government-run universal childcare pre-k
government mandated wages oh let's see
vacations healthy food retirement
everything's free free free they even
push government mandated gun
confiscation from law-abiding citizens
socialism 101 and it is now the status
quo there are no moderates inside the
Democratic Party now we start our debate
analysis with creepy sleepy crazy Joe
303 300 is one strong poll numbers have
taken a dive and for good reason well if
you ever had a fastball it's long gone I
don't think even has a well softball and
by most accounts Biden's debate
performance was a rambling confused
disaster the only person interrupting
Joe was Joe look at your screen all
starts with an apparent problem inside a
Biden's mouth this is very bizarre this
whole thing here look at this a measure
to require expanded background checks
died on the Senate floor if you couldn't
get it done after Sandy Hook why should
voters give you another chance
because I got done before
I'm the only one up here ever beat the
NRA only one ever be generally I believe
it or not it only got worse from there
it was not a good night for Biden
here's more tape the option I'm
proposing is a medicare for all in
Medicare for choice the president think
my friend for a month is a young
congressman young councilman play the
radio make sure the television the
excuse me make sure you have the record
player on at night the phone make sure
the kids hear words I'm the vice
president United States hate to say it I
don't want to see his medical records he
looks like he's aged 20 years since he
left office I don't know why
Biden's performance was actually so bad
some of the other Democrats on stage
actually questioned the state of mind oh
yeah they went there take a look do not
have to buy you just said that you just
said that two minutes ago you just said
two minutes ago that they would have to
buy it you said they would have to buy
to buy in if Paulo fire you know you
forgetting what you said is Maddox could
be in for him
what you said just two minutes ago
I mean I can't believe that you set two
minutes ago that they had to buy in and
now you're saying they don't have to buy
you're forgetting that there are
definitely moments where you listen to
Joe Biden and you just wonder but I
don't know look senator are you saying
no I'm definitely not saying that
because I listen to Joe Biden over the
years and often felt like there were
times that he is going on or meandering
in his oh they're going there maybe he
just had a really bad night maybe he's
not a great debater maybe he's not good
at speaking in campaigning now Sarah
Palin I thought beat him in that debate
pretty handily one thing is certain if
Biden somehow limps across the finish
line wins his party's nomination I think
the president President Trump I think
he'll be pretty happy with that result
anyway no matter who the president faces
in the general election Oh frankly we
can all expect Democrats to once again
weaponize the politics of race now we
see it every two and four years I have
given the history on this show many many
times they pretty much call half of
America racist white supremacist
Republicans a racist sexist misogynist
homophobic xenophobic Islamophobic oh
they want thirty-year water they want to
kill children they want Grandma and
Grandpa eat dog food and cat food before
it damn Paul Ryan throw them over a
cliff didn't change last night they were
in rare form
racism in America is endemic it is
foundational we can mark the creation of
this country not at the 4th of July 1776
but August 20th 1619 when the first
kidnapped Africa
was brought to this country against his
will and in bondage and as a slave a
racist racism racism racial bias
systemic racism racism the racist
systemic racism the systemic racism
racist white supremacy racism white
supremacy racism racism white supremacy
is racist systemic racism is systemic
racism there is institutional
segregation in this country now last
night when Democrats were busy playing
the race card that it dedicated a lot of
time to really pushing their insane
socialist policies Medicare for all very
expensive and you can't have private
insurance take a look on Medicare for
all costs are going to go up for
wealthier individuals and costs are
going to go up for giant corporations
but for hardworking families across this
country costs are going to go down and
that's how it should work every study
done shows that Medicare for all is the
most cost effective approach to
providing health care to every man woman
and child in this country anyone who
can't afford it gets automatically
enrolled in the in the Medicare type
option we have a setter but guess what
of the hundred and sixty million people
who like their health care now they can
keep it now when you hear Medicare for
all with no private insurance option
okay as bad as Obamacare keep your
doctor plan saved money was think of
that a thousand times worse with no exit
escape hatch as it stands now because of
Obamacare nearly forty percent of all US
counties nearly half the country they
only have one insurance option in the
Obamacare market only one choice that's
40 percent of the country premiums yeah
nobody saved money premiums have
skyrocketed and many people lost their
doctors and the federal price tag for
all this suffering will be trillions of
dollars under Medicare for all that
system but will even be worse you don't
get to keep your doctor plan in fact in
a Medicare for All system every American
will even lose their private health
insurance the government would be the
only insurer and guess what to top it
off your taxes they're going to explode
that's right according to multiple
studies look at Bernie's Medicaid
Medicare for all planet comes with an
estimated price tag of 24 to 36 trillion
that's with the T dollars over 10 years
in other words our entire federal budget
is only 4 trillion a year well to put it
another way all of your income taxes
will need to pretty much double just to
cover that cost of that one program does
it include the green New Deal and
there's more but it's almost every
Democrat yep they support a version of
the insanely expensive green New Deal to
battle so called claim climate change
look at your screen Bernie Sanders he
wants to spend a whopping I'm trying to
figure out scratching my conservative
head of here 16 trillion dollars 16
trillion even the so-called moderate Amy
Klobuchar has a plan that cost more than
a trillion dollars that's on the low end
but that's just the tip of the iceberg
for Democrats and their big socialist
plans literally to take the greatest
system of wealth creation pretty much
destroyed about 24 hours take a look we
should be talking about rehabilitation
nobody should be in jail for a
non-violent crime I'm going to do
something unprecedented tonight my
campaign will now give a freedom
dividend of $1,000 a month for an entire
year to ten American families someone
watching this at home right now start
with our babies by providing Universal
child care for every baby age zero to
five universal pre-k for every
three-year-old and four-year-old in this
country every one up here
favors an assault weapon pin everyone up
here favors magazine limitations this is
an incredible burden on millions of
millions of young people who did nothing
wrong except try to get the education
they need we are going to cancel all
student
in this country come on a Harrison it's
not about cost is about an investment
every time you hear the word from a
politician about investment that means
raise your taxes and we're investing
that's what we're doing but one of the
more shocking proposals from last
night's debate came from bado bozo
robert francis O'Rourke who made it
perfectly clear he's coming for your
guns get ready you said quote Americans
who own ar-15s and ak-47s will have to
sell them to the government all of them
you know the critics call this
confiscation are you proposing taking
away their guns and how would this work
I am hell yes we're gonna take your
ar-15 your ak-47
hell yes only the criminals will have
those if you stand back and observe all
the Democrats and their radical
extremist proposals are going to find
one common theme centralization of power
and money in order to protect
law-abiding Americans from themselves it
is a scary ideology America doesn't
reject it I see a lot of trouble ahead